let's talk about gamestop i think it's
important to call out that uh the folks
on reddit which is obviously not on
robin hood uh that identified the short
squeeze opportunity ended up being right
and i think that gets lost in all of
this right as they basically identified
this short squeeze opportunity they went
ahead they exploited it and uh for all
intents and purposes they uh applied
quite a bit of pressure to a number of
very large uh wall street firms some of
that was on robin hood some of that was
done elsewhere but that you know that's
kind of a quick summary of the situation
when you think about that uh and you you
know talk to somebody in private it's
like how do you describe that situation
was it something that uh you all saw
pretty early on happening did it only
really become uh kind of the forefront
once there was the pressure to the large
firms like just what is your
recollection of like when you first
became aware of of that kind of whole
situation that was transpiring oh man
well uh there's so much that happened in
that time period right um
i mean there there was so many things
going on so it's hard
hard to say where to start i mean you
had um
basically
you know i was coming back home from uh
from the east coast back to the west
coast
in early january at the start of the new
year and typically at the start of the
new year you get um an influx of people
just generally interested in investing
so you know people have new year's
resolutions um you have
um you know people getting their their
year-end bonuses
so there there's a lot of just the
natural kind of seasonal interest in
investing at around that time you also
had sort of the
the remnants of the election and then
the insurrection in january uh
and you know the pandemic was was very
much flaring up so uh people were were
inside um
and you know dealing with sort of the
the peak cases and and uh and pandemic
activity so we were very much still
locked down
um and then i think people had gotten
stimulus checks at the end of of the
previous year as well so the confluence
of all these factors led to
just the robin hood
climbing through the app store you know
we were we were first hitting sort of
like
um
number one in the financial category and
then eventually ended up actually number
one overall you know ahead of
social media products like tick tock and
instagram and facebook which is pretty
uh pretty unprecedented for a financial
product and a brokerage product so
um
you know we were trying to keep
everything together and you know looking
around corners best we could
to make sure we were stable and up for
customers i remember at that time that
was my number one priority because at
the beginning of the pandemic march of
2020
we had uh we had some some downtime
right as markets were getting super
volatile and
that was very disappointing to me kind
of as an engineer who built the product
right you never want your service to be
down for
um for a significant period of time
especially you know when there's there's
a lot of market volatility so that was
kind of fresh in my mind just making
sure that the investments that that we
made um on the technology
were
paying off and you know we were really
being tested at that point with some
growth that we hadn't seen in the past
and then um of course you know we
couldn't have anticipated the
the five sigma the sort of one in 3.5
million uh event which resulted on the
the week of january 28th where basically
the kind of viral social media activity
all funneled through um a handful of
stocks and
and really a handful of brokerages um
robinhood kind of
being the the bulk of it but also lots
of other brokerages had to deal with
with similar things both before we
restricted the stocks and and after so
uh the way i describe it is you know the
markets
as they currently
were
were set were not really built
for that type of activity and you can
kind of see a bunch of assumptions
breaking and and you know that that's
what led robinhood to restrict uh
opening positions and that's why many
other brokerages
did that as part of their risk
mitigation procedures one way or another
before and after
our restrictions
so most of the questions fall in three
buckets around all this stuff uh and um
there's a whole bunch of professionals
whether they're journalists they're
politicians they're uh et cetera that'll
kind of do like the fact-finding mission
so i'm gonna leave it to them to to do
their jobs frankly i don't think that
stuff is as interesting as just kind of
getting your perspective here so the
first thing is uh what are in hindsight
the things that you wish that you'd
either done differently or that uh were
like the lessons learned right so you
know hindsight bias is amazing we get to
sit here uh kind of safely on the other
side of this for for you if robin hood
and say okay what would you have done
differently or what did you learn from
that entire experience and kind of chaos
yeah i mean i think uh i think the
straightforward one is just
communicating with with customers and
letting them know sort of like with more
specificity what what could happen uh
what could not happen we did we did
communicate to customers uh
actually quite prolifically but you know
i look back at some of those
communications and especially in the
days leading up to
um
to january 28th we would we would send
information about market volatility and
how to protect yourself and you know uh
information about you know long-term
investing
and um
i think hindsight being 2020 we had no
idea we would we would have to restrict
these stocks uh up until the morning of
january 28th but you know being being a
little bit upfront and preparing people
for possibility um
you know i think would have gone gone a
long way just saying hey you know
in addition to this information about
what volatility means you know this is
what a brokerage could do in response to
volatility including you know
restricting these stocks um probably
would have
tempered a little bit of kind of the
conspiracy theories that that emerged of
you know the brokers colluding with with
the hedge funds um
which you know despite
all of our efforts all of my efforts
still remain you know people still out
there
uh think that robin hood
colluded with hedge funds which you know
is flabbergasting to me even even though
all the the mountain of actual evidence
uh
i think pretty pretty categorically
explains that you know we had to impose
these restrictions because we we got a
big collateral call uh from nscc uh
which
you know has completely has nothing to
do with with hedge funds whatsoever
um
but you know uh
stemming that at the beginning as early
as possible um probably would have been
a little bit more effective
but you know you yourself probably know
it's it's very very hard to stop the
spread of misinformation
on social media and
you know a simple a simple lie um
is is just more compelling than a
complicated truth a lot of the times and
for some reason it's like collusion is
like the
the word of the decade you know
people love talking about collusion one
way or another if it's like you know
collusion with russians for for one
election collusion with someone else for
another election collusion with hedge
funds people people like to think that
you know that that's you know it's it's
a it's a very very tempting narrative
and unfortunately you know tempting
narratives
win the day in uh in this age of social
media so uh i think there's a lot of
things we could have done better a lot
of lessons and a lot of things you know
we have done better since then including
communicating more transparently um
really ramping up our our customer
support to make sure we're we're there
for customers and generally articulating
our values a little bit better telling
people hey we are a safety first company
we believe in democratization absolutely
we want you to do everything that you
want to do within the confines of sort
of law and regulation but we want to
make sure that especially the young
people and the first-time investors on
robinhood are having a great experience
have great support and have access to
all the information they need to to
become long-term investors